vous siégez au parlement européen dans
la commission énergie monsieur voc tanga
avec des factures on disait énergétique
qui explose calculé sur le prix du gaz
alors est ce qu'il y a moyen de réduire
cette facture au niveau européen en
partant du prix réel par exemple du
nucléaire disent les français ou ou des
énergies renouvelables est-ce que ça
finalement c'est aussi un problème de
calculs énergétiques mais bien sûr on
voit aujourd'hui qui a toute une série
de multinationales notamment du
nucléaire qui se font véritablement des
profits invraisemblable parce que pour
eux le coût de production n'a pas
tellement évolué donc on voit que le
prix du gaz par exemple explose mais le
coût de production du nucléaire c'est
autre chose mais ces multinationales
vente quand même leur électricité au
prix de l'électricité du marché et
arrive de cette manière là à faire ce
qu'on appelle des surprofits un donc
d'empocher des milliards au niveau
européen pour en disant voilà on va
faire payer les gens effectivement ce
n'est pas acceptable donc l'idée devrait
être et ça on devrait le faire dans
chaque pays de dire voilà c'est sûr
profit on les prend et on utilise pour
faire baisser les factures des gens et
ça c'est possible parce qu'aujourd'hui
en belgique par exemple la tva sur
l'énergie est à 21% c'est le même taux
que pour le champagne le caviar vous
trouvez que c'est normal que lequel
vient un qui est un produit de luxe soit
considérée équivalent à l'énergie dont
l'énergie est un droit fondamental des
gens et pour ça il faut des mesures
fortes que pour l'instant on voit pas
vraiment parce que les factures continue
d'exploser 700 euros de plus 1000 euros
de plus pour certaines personnes cette
année c'est inacceptable
[Musique]